[Musique]
écoutez moi conclut t il du gène à dire
par deux m'a dit il y avait des bruits
et trams immeuble où l'air sont bons
aujourd'hui quel parfum eau mais voilà
d'où vient cette bonne odeur fait d'une
fleur
mais non mais non feinte enfouis à
merveille un futur mon arbre il faut que
j'annonce la nouvelle à melchior m
malgré tout mes plus beaux maître malka
une bonne nouvelle à vous annoncer que
je digère ray mon plus beau plus
facilement
l'arbre a fait un bruit effrayant mais
non en afrique on va alors se trame ne
l'ont pas de tour d'afrique comme j'en
ai jamais vu il y à la fois une fleur et
des grands parents comme des perles
terme free est rentable
un fruit pas comme les autres et qui
sent bon beau
[Musique]
où
mon qu'elle parte on dirait qu'il vient
de cet arbre mais c'est ce fruit qui
sent si bon chic et n'a envie de goûter
aux mets délicieux et amoureux c'est
exquis vous vous dit quand tu as repris
merveilleux je vous le croire lorsque
jeune frère et ma fille venait le voir
la comédie aimable vous allez voir un
fruit de quoi vous n'avez jamais vu à
frire unique au monde
woippy devant vous je souhaite le revoir
chaque carte classique lui de plomb
comment manger on me l'a volé on
enlevait grain mon garçon dans ce cas là
il faut place on a toujours trahi ça
éloigne les adieux
les gourmands et les curieux alors je
suis mon conseil faisant de thourotte en
épouvantail d'un gouverneur à moi
dépôt-vente base le rapport à tout le
monde pour mot ce cas je m'ennuie et ctu
et titus a dit pas un grand yaka jeu ça
n'était pas joli aperçu tout un art r il
se dirigeait vers le jardin de l'herbier
et mais j'aurais dû faire une petite
visite et je vous suis grande yaka enfin
meyboom by épouvante est que souvent par
voler c'est le plus possible
il ressemble au grand yaka et il rit
alors tu sais tu travailles tu t'amuses
avis quand on frappe c'est le grand yaka
en viande et en europe
métier très beau ce que tu fais là riz
c'est une statue et oiseau mi koné mory
au wigan la caf
c'est un vent de partout quoi c'est très
bien petite suisse s'élevait tué et lui
même qui quelque chose ici parce que je
n'ai pas terminé grand encore bon allez
montez calamiteux chercher mais collier
tous mes bijoux oui tu veux que ma
statue soit très belle et très sérieuse
et gecko craqua au jeu titus il a vu
d'autres chevaux du mental
je suis très beau comme un cerveau moi
ce que tu es magnifique et en vous
pleurent moins je me plais beaucoup
je suis très contente de moi très
satisfait du meu deux mois qu'on ne veut
pas un épouvantail de luxe
et après après de l'autre les doigts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]